Mình một tháng 5 kêu thủ tường Thái Lan ông Thạc Sien thì nào trời chính thức được chả tử gió, sau khoảng tạm tháng 8,
khép lại một trong những buồn anh chính thịt về chủ hi nhất, tả nước này trong nhiều tư ghê.
Ông Thạc Sien mạnh mỹ sảo tuổi, dời nhà tu, con con, bằng cục trong sự chào đón của giá định và hàng trong những hộ.
Con gái ông đúng thời là kêu thủ tường Thái Lan và phê tông đàn Sien à hoa trời của gó mặt.
Chưa đỏ huy năm hình hải vác, ông Thạc Sien cho lại thái Lan sau mỗi lắm năm sống Lưu Vông,
đer chúc thánh mức án lên quan gắt gạo vôc lòng quên và xuống đột lựa íc khi còn giữ trực thủ tường ra đoạn hành lệ một hành lệ sấu.
Bà nâng mắt đầu tháng 2 sau đó được nhà vô thái Lan, ín xa còn một năm.
Cuy nhiên ông Thạc Sien chì ở trong trại giám và giới trước khi được chuyển tới bình viện.
Bởi lý rõ xe quế và Lưu Lai tài khu đều trí đọc biệt trong nhiều tháng.
Tói cao thái Lan sau đó khi lộn biệt kéo ra trên dành điều trí là khu cự thiết.
Và yêu cầu ông tiếp tục chấp hành án tù hồi cuối tháng tư lòng Lai, ông chính thức được bộ tù pháp trở phép gia tù trước thái hành với điều kiện ông sẽ phải đều thí bị giám xa để tự trong thời gian còn lại của bà nắng.
Ông Thạc Sien từng lên nhân vật quán hưởng lưỡn trong chính trường thái Lan xuất hơi hai thập nghiên,
sọng anh hưởng bộng được cho rồi đả suy ra mù sau thời gian ngồi tù và kết quả một cửa công như kì vọng của đảng phy lời hồi đổn ông Lai.